foreign
how we doing
hi John hi George I'm so nervous hey we
are super nervous too
especially George because I'm
uncomfortable I'm so scared exactly
you're safe here you're good you're safe
you're safe here what's up Shawna okay
so
um
my husband and I we never separated but
he left nine years ago
um my one daughter got a brain tumor my
other one was diagnosed with type 1
diabetes and the house was a bit
stressful
so he left but he was involved and stuff
he didn't live too far from us and it's
been nine years and
um
we had a discussion about us getting
back together
and moving back into her house and
staying in separate rooms while we build
our relationship and one of the
um one of my main things because we
fought about money so much was he had to
do Financial Peace University with me
which has been two months and still
hasn't and brought a 70 000 truck and I
just paid my car off
and I'm feeling super resentful
and
um like there's no you can't have a
conversation because he takes it
personally like he's being attacked
so I'm just wondering
what to do
Sean I can I can hear it in your voice
know this George and I are heartbroken
with you
this is hard
um I can hear it in your voice you know
exactly what's happening
because you have been on this exact
roller coaster before right
[Music]
and for whatever reason whatever story
he told whatever picture he painted
nine years later you're exhausted
you've been creating a warm
sustainable home for two kids who are
going through hell or four kids two of
which are going through hell
and then he waltzes back in my guess is
his lease ran up or he lost a job but
that's a whole other conversation for
you and I he didn't lose the job but he
did need a place to stay yeah that's
exactly right so it's his idea to say
Hey what if we tried to make things work
and I well it was it was both of our
idea like he was he was changed like a
different person and I mean my kids are
all adults ish now I've got to
graduating this year and they were like
super excited and then once he moved in
and we set up boundaries because I'm a
big firm believer in boundaries now I
wasn't in the past
uh he took it very personally and
basically doesn't speak to us and we we
did have a very peaceful home and I have
my own business that I run with my older
daughter and we do very well he needs to
go
and you know and you know that
tell me if I'm wrong he violated the
promise I'm coming to you
you're not wrong
so if you're calling for permission
yes a little but listen
here's the part you can't skip over that
you've skipped over for 10 years
you have to intentionally enter into a
season of grief
for the husband that gave you four kids
and when it got hard he quit
and after you did a decade
of back-breaking work
he waltzed back in and you said hey this
time
it's going to be different because this
is my house now and this is the family
that I have held together
and this is the the young kids that are
now adults that I have had to raise
mostly on my own they got to come play
at your house but I raised them
so here's my boundaries and he's like
because he's a toddler in an adult body
and then you've said hey this is really
important to me
and this is a condition of you coming
back into this house
and he said okay and then he spit on
that conviction with a seventy thousand
dollar truck
yeah that's about it
it is and let me tell you I'm
heartbroken for you he's not on the
phone so I'm not gonna talk bad about
him anymore I'm sad for you
because you let your heart believe again
and it got hurt again by the same guy
right
right I'm so sorry
Shawna the thing is he's a really good
actor and he's going to convince you
that I know I made a mistake but honey
this time it's going to be different I'm
willing to do whatever it takes I want
to be there and then he's going to let
you down again and he's going to violate
your next promise and so right now
there's no way to build trust when he's
proven himself to be untrustworthy with
a pattern of behavior
right and so you need to say you gotta
go
and I don't know if this is ever going
to work but right now for sure it's not
this is going to be a brutal
conversation with your kids I know that
because they have a picture that Mom and
Dad were always going to get back
together and your husband probably told
him actually my kids that have been like
are they done
yeah wow look at hey Mama you raised
your kids right you raised your kids
right I have four amazing children yeah
here's what I really want you to do okay
um
two things number one I want you to
reach out to my friends at betterhelp
okay you can go to betterhelp.com
deloney and they'll give you a discount
I want you to talk to a licensed
counselor because you've been through a
lot the last decade and this is hard and
it's exhausting and it's lonely
the second thing I want you to do is to
reach out to one or two girlfriends in
your area do you have a couple of
friends that you trust with everything I
do I
have friends okay would you take them
out because again George and I are two
Knuckleheads on a radio show okay on a
podcast and so it's easy for us to lob
grenades we're getting one side of a
story all that stuff
I want you guys to help me get through
my day I just want you to know that well
you help our who you help us get through
our day so we're grateful but listen I
want you to take those girlfriends out
you buy the coffee and the bagels I want
you to tell them all that you're
experiencing all you've gone through the
last year
and ask each of them what what do I do
next
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your pass change your future
the my number one best-selling book
about almost this exact moment how do
you deal with the past and ask yourself
that haunting question what do I do now
and it gives you a path forward